[BLANK_AUDIO]
So let me make sure I
have this straight, Doc.
Once we have correctly set up
the model notifications and
delegates, whenever we modify any
managed objects, the views just sync up?
>> That's it, Marty.
The delegate,
the NSFetchResultsController, and
the notifications do all the work for
us.
>> That's fantastic, Doc!
So now that we've
implemented all this for
the Messages app, we can go back to the
future and recover my last algorithm.
>> Hold it, Marty.
We're forgetting one thing.
>> What's that, Doc?
Aren't we creating new objects and
letting everything sync up?
>> Yes, Marty but
that's all in volatile memory!
All this setting and
managing our object models is nice, but
if we're not saving to disk,
we're not persisting, Marty.
Come on Marty, let's go to XCode.